[Music]
arie lions like Junior is our next
Bachelor
and only et was with him on the set of
his first photo shoot
just after the announcement when you get
that call do you even believe it in that
moment do you grab a suit and jump in a
plane yeah no I didn't even grab the 36
year old hasn't been on TV since 2012
when he was runner-up on Emily Maynard's
heart-wrenching season of The
Bachelorette I am definitely going to
marry Emily I don't know anymore
well I would imagine since you're on The
Bachelorette you've learned a lot about
yourself and what you're looking for in
relationships what have you learned in
the past few years it's been tough I
mean I think that since the show I
really haven't felt that same feeling I
had when I was on The Bachelorette and
that's what really drove me to kind of
do this because I knew that I could find
love and it just gave gave me the time
to really put myself in front of
somebody and sort of shed everything and
not worry about work and and all the
other pressures of life and that's what
makes it so amazing I mean you can
really solely concentrate on finding
somebody that's right ari says he has
not been in love since back then have
you talked to Emily Maynard at all as
she given you any advice or will you
speak to her um if she calls all the
answer but no I haven't talked to her we
sort of you know went our separate ways
up to the show and that's fine and she
has a beautiful life the race car driver
in real estate agent told us he's more
ready than ever for marriage and saw his
lack of reality TV time in recent years
as an advantage in finding a real
relationship I've been off of TV so long
I hope some of the girls too on the show
don't know me and then they can get to
know me in a more natural way instead
sort of seeing my season and having a
preconceived notion will you propose at
the end of all this I hope so
The Bachelor premieres Monday January
1st on ABC
[Music]